みなさんお待たせしました
ブーバずに撮っとかあチェッカーをせよとブーブー言いますよ当選者の方について
にょ当選された方にはこちらから
がこちらのチャンネルあそこまでダイレクトメッセージを送るではーず車道名前と指
番号を聞くのでもしごぶっゴフッゴフッ
アース号カーだけレバーゼロス何
まずは缶バッチですこれをさん連れの方にプレゼントしようと思いますはい
この人はズバリ言わせていただきましょうあよ願いしますコメント数3000ハンっ
3186コメント頂きましたにぎあう
ありがとうございますなんと a みんなージョンより cns 本当に行こう
ぜひこれからもプレーず客またあると思うんで待っててください
はいねまず直樹さんどれではまず話せたのは
あれですよね1コメの人にプレゼントということでそうですねいつべ声の方を見ると
美容にもよいでさすが
これあれ
確実にこの3000のだから1番を取ったってことだなぁ
はいえーとした米の方こちらですね
えっと午後直樹さん
上後この地さん会え55な大きい恭平
自然これ iln
な何クリーク f 6な送りさんですよ
ねやいだーっでございます
それ自治米の方は一定です
俺の29名 the 無作為に目せていただきます
はいがいきましょう
ランスメーカーっていうのはその
ゼロから r 鈴までの
ずっとランダムに数字を見つけてるっていう
行ったんですけど
うざい日米から3186合目までの何州の29戸
29名の方に
なんかあげようと思います
ピュアサーバーやっ日終わってるやんって
だいきますよ梅の瞬間ですやはり緊張する
俺がしたろそしてバーンん曜日はだないっ
人気たがないあ人にヘタが無いのよねいませんこの29名の方の
もうすく面とからズームに数えて
てみようと思います
その時にコメントが重複とか
2つコメントしてる人とかはねえ飛ばしていこう
そうです
ではルール企画だねうーん
the saga 初見
の
ん
me
会津をビルド院長が俺もう一にはじゃないけどそういやだ
youtube 持っています
千葉りましたーーー
外決まりましたんああああああた
ラージョヴィて3倉庫
外見シーンはあったりん
ん
中断されてます里はああいうわけだ
何度は設置やでー
設定しましたん
活発当選者
こちらにまあドアって書いてあるんで多分
めっちゃ物等のかターン
net
ペットダイレクトメッセージを送るので是非
呪詛とお名前という日マンゴーの方
ゴキ人数で帰ってください英語部はほんまんよ
なぜみんなで癒さ娘もなぁじゃあ次会2次会で
ブーブー勃起 p to do
なんていただけます1名1名
それでは
3ds ds の当選ションタップします達成時なるムーン
ああああやいよ
大闘技の兆しだろうと思ったので570万の人が当然ですはいじゃあ今からん
数えますねはい
赤瀬西4階車
サルってるー
最高の人当たるれの期待している自分がいる
梅雨たんですねどこどこどこどこにくっ終わったですよ
この人がビジネスの当事者で強さをめでとーございます前後賞あげたいんですけどねぇ
というわけで3ベースはスーダンの
ところに行くことになりましたこれはございません
本当に皆さんさん前にコメント以上のコメント本当にありがとうございました
素晴らしいですねあのまた本当に全館
以外だったら
もっとどでかいプレゼント
良いしようと思ってるんでだねビジョンとかば母をとって里カバーだとか
プレステ3とが取れなうん gu とか
wiiu いやうちガンエフェクトから
だろまで際ハブとかまるで博文音声墨液とそれだけあのーの違う違うん
嵩文
これからもぜひ
プレゼンばからなかった方もまだチャンスはあります
このためが続く限り会前の曲は
あのしていこうと思うんで
またよろしくお願いします
じゃ台前後またよろしく
じゃあ
思っ